6 37 all right time to get your kids
ready to go back to school it does
require quite a bit of planning though
it's not just the supplies you need to
buy and the bedtimes to figure out again
there are some things your students need
they have to have it in order to go back
to class they sure do and they might not
necessarily like this part of it we're
talking about vaccinations this morning
you know just stings and then then it's
all gone right mary jane billy joining
us live from the southern nevada health
district with more on what you do need
mary
jane yeah good morning i mean school is
right around the corner it's coming up
fast which is why dr chris choice says
don't wait to vaccinate nevada law
requires immunizations for child care
schools and colleges unless excused
because of a religious belief or a
medical condition the requirements are
for beginning kindergartners students
entering the 7th grade and 12th grade
and college students and any student new
to a nevada school district dr choice
says now is the time to double check to
see if your child is updated on these
vaccines and students must submit proof
of immunity to tetanus diphtheria
measles mumps and rubella before
enrollment
for university students they have to
prove
that
they are vaccinated for the tdap uh
tetanus pertussis and uh
dipped area so
uh if they've had that going to middle
school then they're fine but that is uh
required and they also have to uh prove
that they were vaccinated for the
missiles mumps rubella
varicella
the meningitis vaccine is also required
for college students under the age of 23
who are entering as a freshman
vaccination records are available at
your pediatrician's office or you can
obtain your records online and many
healthcare providers here in the state
offer low-cost or free vaccines to
parents under the children for vaccines
program and you can also make an
appointment here at the southern nevada
health district if you would like to get
your child vaccinated reporting live
mary jane vallieza live local now